YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE INSIDE A
QUINCY COURTROOM IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
THIS IS WHERE BRIAN WALSHE
CHARGED WITH THE MURDER NOW OF
HIS WIFE ANA IS FACING CHARGES.
LET'S LISTEN IN.
>> YOU ARE ALSO CHARGED WITH --
OF A BODY WITHOUT LAWFUL
AUTHORITY, TO WILLFULLY DIG UP
OR REMOVE HUMAN REMAINS.
NOT GUILTY PLEA HAS BEEN
ENTERED.
>> YOUR HONOR [ INAUDIBLE ].
>> YOUR HONOR, WE'RE NOT
CONTESTING BAIL OR PROBABLE
CAUSE, WE WOULD ASK THAT HE
BE --
>> THANK YOU, BUT I HAVE TO
SATISFY MYSELF WITH PROBABLE
CAUSE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, YOUR HONOR.
>> THE DEFENDANT IS NOW BEFORE
THE COURT CHARGED WITH MURDER OF
HIS WIFE ANA WALSHE ALSO -- OF A
BODY.
ANA WAS 39 YEARS OLD, THE MOTHER
OF THREE CHILDREN, 2, 4 AND 6.
ANA WORKED IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
SPENDING HER TIME WEEKDAYS
BETWEEN D.C. DURING THE WEEK AND
STAYING IN HER HOUSE IN COHASSET
WHERE SHE LIVED WITH THE
DEFENDANT AND THEIR THREE KIDS.
ON JANUARY 4th OF 2023, COHASSET
POLICE RECEIVED A CALL FROM HER
WASHINGTON, D.C. EMPLOYER
INDICATING THAT SHE WAS MISSING.
SHE WAS DUE TO REPORT TO WORK ON
JANUARY 4th, BUT DID NOT APPEAR.
SHE HAD A FLIGHT ON JANUARY 3rd
FROM LOGAN TO D.C. WHICH SHE DID
NOT BOARD.
COHASSET POLICE WENT TO THEIR
HOUSE FOR A WELL BEING CHECK.
IT WAS ONLY AT THIS TIME WHEN
THEY MET WITH THE DEFENDANT THAT
HE FIRST REPORTED HIS WIFE
MISSING.
DEFENDANT STATED HIS WIFE LEFT
THE HOUSE AT APPROXIMATELY 6:00
A.M. ON JANUARY 1st, NEW YEAR'S
DAY.
HE STATED SHE TOOK AN UBER OR
LYFT TO GO TO THE AIRPORT, THAT
SHE WAS RETURNING TO D.C. FOR
WORK.
RECORDS WERE CHECKED AND THERE
WAS NO UBER OR LYFTS TO THAT
HOUSE ON JANUARY 1st.
DEFENDANT SAID HE HAD NOT SPOKEN
TO HIS WIFE SINCE THE EARLY
MORNING HOURS ON NEW YEAR'S DAY.
COHASSET POLICE WERE GRANTED
PERMISSION TO BING ANA'S PHONE.
IT INDICATED IT WAS STATIONARY
IN THE AREA OF THE COHASSET
HOUSE ON NEW YEAR'S EVE UNTIL
3:14 A.M. ON JANUARY 2nd.
THERE WAS NO OUTGOING CALLS MADE
AT THAT TIME.
AT 3:14 A.M. ON THE 2nd WAS
TURNED OFF.
DEFENDANT STATED ANA SHOULD HAVE
BEEN WEARING A DRESS, BLACK
JACKET, HUNTER BOOTS, WATCH,
RING, AS WELL AS CARRYING A
PRADA PURSE.
DEFENDANT GAVE A TIMELINE OF
6:00 OR 6:10 A.M. ON THE 1st
WHEN HE LAST SAW HER.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS DESCRIBE
HIS ACTIONS ON THE DAYS FROM
JANUARY 1st.
DEFENDANT INDICATED ON JANUARY
1st AT 3:00 P.M. HE DID SOME
ERRANDS AND WENT TO HIS MOTHER'S
HOUSE IN SWAMPSCOTT BUT GOT LOST
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE HIS
PHONE.
HE SAID HE KNEW HE WAS LOST WHEN
HE SAW A PIRATE SHIP ON ROUTE 1.
DEFENDANT STATED HE STAYED 15
MINUTES THEN WENT TO WHOLE FOODS
AND CVS.
SURVEILLANCE WAS CHECKED AND DID
HE NOT ENTER EITHER OF THOSE
STORES.
ON JANUARY 1st DEFENDANT GOOGLED
USING HIS SON'S iPAD SOME OF THE
SEARCHES ARE AS FOLLOWS, KEEP IN
MIND THAT THE DEFENDANT SAID HE
LEFT AT 6:00 A.M. AT 4:55 A.M.
ON JANUARY 1st HE SEARCHED HOW
LONG BEFORE A BODY STARTS TO
SMELL?
AT 4:58 A.M., HOW TO STOP A BODY
FROM DECOMPOSING.
AT 5:20 A.M. HE SEARCHED HOW
TO -- A BODY.
AT 5:47 A.M. TEN WAYS TO DISPOSE
OF A DEAD BODY IF YOU REALLY
NEED TO.
AT 6:25 A.M. ON THE 1st, HOW
LONG FOR SOMEONE TO BE MISSING
TO INHERIT.
AT 6:34 A.M. ON THE 1st CAN YOU
THROW AWAY BODY PARTS?
AT 9:29 A.M. WHAT DOES
FORMALDEHYDE DO?
AT 9:34 A.M. ON THE 1st, HOW
LONG DOES DNA LAST?
AT 9:59 A.M., CAN IDENTIFICATION
BE MADE ON PARTIAL REMAINS?
AT 11:34 A.M. DISMEMBERMENT AND
THE BEST WAYS TO DISPOSE OF A
BODY.
AT 11:44 HOW TO CLEAN BLOOD FROM
WOODEN FLOOR.
AT 11:56 ON THE 1st LUMINOL TO
DETECT BLOOD.
AT 1:08 WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
PUT BODY PARTS IN AMINE I CAN'T?
AT 1:21 P.M. DOES IS IT BETTER
TO THROW CRIME SCENE CLOTHES
AWAY OR WASH THEM.
THERE WAS ALSO INFORMATION
GAINED FROM THE DEFENDANT'S
PHONE WHICH SHOWED ON JANUARY
2nd HE WAS AT HOME GOODS IN
NORWELL WHERE HE PURCHASED THREE
RUGS.
THERE WERE ALSO MORE GOOGLE
SEARCHES ON JANUARY 2nd.
AT 12:45 P.M., HACKSAW BEST TOOL
TO DISMEMBER.
AT 1:10 P.M., CAN YOU BE CHARGED
WITH MURDER WITHOUT A BODY?
AT 1:14 P.M., CAN YOU IDENTIFY A
BODY WITHOUT -- WITH BROKEN
TEETH?
ON JANUARY 2nd FOLLOWING THOSE
THE DEFENDANT WAS SEEN ON
SURVEILLANCE AT THE HOME DEPOT
IN ROCKLAND AND CHECKING WITH
SURVEILLANCE THE DEFENDANT IS
OBSERVED ON SECURITY CAMERA
PUSHING A CART, ITEMS INCLUDED
CLEANING PRODUCTS, MOPS,
BRUSHES, TAPE, TARP, A TYVEK
SUIT WITH BOOT COVERS, BUCKETS,
GOGGLES, BAKING SODA, A HATCHET.
HE HAD A FACEMASK AND RUBBER
GLOVES ON AT THE TIME HE WAS
PUSHING THE CART IN HOME DEPOT.
AT 5:32 HE WAS SEEN IN HINGHAM
REMOVING GLOVES AND A MASK.
DATA FROM HIS PHONE ALSO TRACKED
HIS WHEREABOUTS ON JANUARY 3rd.
LOCATIONS WERE TRAVELED AT 4:27
ON JANUARY 3rd TO AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX IN ABINGTON.
SURVEILLANCE SHOWS THE
DEFENDANT'S VOLVO AS WELL AS A
MALE FITTING THE DEFENDANT'S
APPEARANCE EXITING A CAR NEAR
THE DUMPSTER.
HE WALKS TO THE DUMPSTER
CARRYING A GARBAGE BAG.
HE'S LEANING AND IT APPEARS TO
BE HEAVY AS HE HAS TO HEFT IT
INTO THE DUMPSTER.
HE WALKS TO THE DUMPSTER WITH
THE GARBAGE BAG AND LEAVES IT.
ON 4:48 HE HIT ANOTHER COMPLEX
IN ABINGTON AND AT 5:10 P.M.
CELLPHONE SHOWS RECORDS AT
ANOTHER APARTMENT IN BROCKTON.
VIDEO SHOWS A PARTY CONSISTENT
WITH HIS APPEARANCE AND HIS
VOLVO.
AGAIN, HE DISCARDED ITEMS IN THE
DUMPSTER.
ON JANUARY 3rd THAT SAME DAY AT
1:02 P.M. HE DID SOME MORE
GOOGLE SEARCHES.
WHAT HAPPENS TO HAIR ON A DEAD
BODY?
AT 1:13 P.M., WHAT IS THE RATE
OF DECOMPOSITION OF A BODY FOUND
IN A PLASTIC BAG COMPARED TO ON
A SURFACE IN THE WOODS?
AT 1:20 P.M., CAN BAKING SODA
MASK OR MAKE A BODY SMELL GOOD?
ON JANUARY 4th THE FOLLOWING DAY
THE DEFENDANT WENT TO HOME GOODS
AND T.J. MAXX.
HE PURCHASED TOWELS, AS WELL AS
BATH MATS AND MEN'S CLOTHING.
AT 4:15 THAT DAY ON THE 4th HE
WENT TO LOWE'S WHERE HE
PURCHASED SQUEEJEES AND A TRASH
CAN.
ON JANUARY 4th WHEN COHASSET
POLICE WENT TO THE HOUSE ON THE
WELL BEING CHECK, OFFICERS
OBSERVED HIS VOLVO WITH SEATS
DOWN AND A PLASTIC LINER IN THE
BACK OF THE CAR.
THE NEXT DAY A VIEW OF THE VOLVO
SHOWED HIS SEATS FOLDED DOWN,
FLOOR MATS WITH SOME DIRT AND A
CARPET APPEARED TO SHOW FRESH
VACUUM STREAKS.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE LINER THE
DEFENDANT SAID HE THREW IT IN
THE TRASH.
CHEMISTS LATER ANALYZED THE CAR
AND THERE WAS THE PRESENCE OF
BLOOD IN THE CAR.
ON JANUARY 5th REVIEW OF THE
DATA FROM DEFENDANT'S PHONE
SHOWED HIS PHONE TRAVELED AT
8:00 A.M. FIRST TO HIS DAY CARE
AND THEN TO SWAMPSCOTT WHERE HIS
MOTHER RESIDES.
THE PHONE TRAVELED TO THE
COMPLEX WHERE HIS MOTHER LIVES
AT 9:30 A.M., WENT FOR ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES AROUND THE BUILDING
TO THE SOUTHEAST CORNER.
IN THE SOUTHEAST CORNER OF THAT
COMPLEX IS WHERE THERE WAS A
DUMPSTER.
THE DUMPSTER WAS LATER SECURED
AND SEARCHED.
ON JANUARY 8th POLICE AND CRIME
SCENE SERVICES SEARCHED THE
HOUSE IN COHASSET.
THEY FOUND BLOOD IN THE
BASEMENT, A KNIFE WITH THE
PRESENCE OF BLOOD, THE KNIFE WAS
DAMAGED.
A SECOND KNIFE WAS ALSO FOUND IN
THAT BASEMENT.
IN ADDITION THERE WAS HEAVY DUTY
LARGE TARP, PLASTIC LINERS
PURCHASED FROM THAT HOME DEPOT.
AS PART OF THE INVESTIGATION
POLICE CHECKED FOR ACTIVITY ON
ANA'S CREDIT CARDS, BANKS,
FLIGHTS, THERE WAS NO ACTIVITY
SINCE SHE WAS LAST SEEN ON
JANUARY 1st.
POLICE ALSO TRIED TO TRACK DOWN
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE BAGS THAT
THE DEFENDANT WAS SEEN THROWING
IN THE DUMPSTER EARLIER.
THIS WAS OVER IN ABINGTON.
THESE BAGS AND WHAT WAS IN THEM
WERE ALREADY PICKED UP AND TAKEN
TO A LOCATION FOR SHREDDING AND
TO BE INCINERATED.
BY THE TIME POLICE LOCATED THAT
THEY WERE ALREADY DESTROYED.
HOWEVER, INVESTIGATORS DID
SECURE A SEARCH OF THE DUMPSTERS
FROM DEFENDANT'S MOTHER'S
COMPLEX IN SWAMPSCOTT.
IT WAS SEARCHED AT A TRANSFER
STATION IN PEABODY.
INVESTIGATORS RECOVERED TEN
TRASH BAGS.
INSIDE THE TRASH BAGS MANY OF
THESE ITEMS CONTAINED STAINS
CONSISTENT WITH BLOOD, IN FACT,
A LOT.
AMONG THE ITEMS SECURED WERE
TOWELS, RAGS, SLIPPERS, TAPE,
TYVEK SUIT, GLOVES, CLEANING
AGENTS, CARPETS, RUGS, HUNTER
BOOTS, PRADA PURSE, A COVID-19
CARD IN THE NAME OF ANA WALSHE.
A HACKSAW, A HATCHET AND SOME
CUTTING SHEARS.
THE PURSE AND BOOTS WERE
DESCRIBED AS WHAT ANA WAS LAST
SEEN IN.
A PORTION OF THE RUG WAS HEAVILY
STAINED WITH RED BROWN STAINS,
THE SUBSTANCE WAS CONSISTENT
WITH ALSO HAVING BAKING SODA ON.
THERE WAS A PORTION OF A
NECKLACE CONSISTENT WITH ONE
THAT ANA HAD BEEN SEEN WEARING
IN PHOTOS.
THE STATE CRIME LAB CONFIRMED
TESTING ON CERTAIN SELECTED
ITEMS THAT WERE RECOVERED FROM
THOSE TRASH BAGS.
THERE WAS HUMAN BLOOD FOUND ON
THEM AND THEN THEY WERE SENT FOR
DNA TESTING.
THE FINDINGS ARE AS FOLLOWS.
ON THE SLIPPERS IN THE INTERIOR
ANA AND BRIAN WALSHE WERE
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE DNA ON THOSE
SLIPPERS WHICH HAD BLOOD ON
THEM.
ON THE EXTERIOR ANA AND BRIAN
WALSHE CONTRIBUTED TO THE DNA
FOUND ON THOSE SLIPPERS.
THE TYVEK SUIT, ON THE INTERIOR
CUFFS ANNA AND BRIAN WALSHE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE DNA THAT WAS
LEFT ON THEM.
ON THE EXTERIOR PARTIALLY -- ON
THE EXTERIOR LEFT PANT LEG ANA
WALSHE CONTRIBUTED TO THE DNA.
ON THE INTERIOR RIGHT SLEEVE ANA
WALSHE WAS A CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
DNA THAT WAS FOUND ON THE TYVEK
SUIT.
THERE WAS TISSUES WHICH FOUND
THAT ANA WALSHE CONTRIBUTED TO.
DNA.
THERE WAS ONE OTHER EARLIER
GOOGLE SEARCH WHICH YOU WILL
NOTE ON DECEMBER 27th DEFENDANT
GOOGLED WHAT'S THE BEST STATE TO
DIVORCE.
RATHER THAN DIVORCE IT IS
BELIEVED THAT BRIAN WALSHE
DISMEMBERED ANA WALSHE AND
DISCARDED HER BODY.
THE BAGS WERE LATER DISCARDED IN
SWAMPSCOTT AND CONTAINED ANA'S
PROPERTY AND THE ITEMS USED TO
CLEAN UP AS WELL AS THE DNA THAT
WAS LEFT BEHIND.
THE COMMONWEALTH IS ASKING THE
DEFENDANT BE HELD WITHOUT BAIL
FOR THE MURDER OF HIS WIFE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NO, YOUR HONOR.
THANK YOU.
>> DEFENDANT WILL BE HELD
WITHOUT BAIL PENDING INDICTMENT.